mais d'abord la convocation de l'ancien
président de la république et ce
sentiment que son bras de fer avec les
magistrats n'est pas prêt de se terminer
guillaume bertrand pour un ancien
président de la république c'est une
première le tribunal a ordonné
l'audition de nicolas sarkozy en tant
que témoin au procès des sondages de
l'elysée un témoignage que le ministère
public estime nécessaire à la
manifestation de la vérité san des
prévenus étaient de proches
collaborateurs de l'ancien chef de
l'état claude guéant ou encore patrick
buisson pour l'association anticor
partie civile dans ce dossier si nicolas
sarkozy n'est pas sur le banc des
accusés il est en tout cas au coeur du
procès et nous allons parler en réalité
que des sondages de l'elysée
c'est-à-dire de sa manière d'exercer le
pouvoir le temps de son mandat entre
2007 et 2012 c'est à dire l'utilisation
massive de sondage des sondages qui
coûte cher 7 5 millions d'euros d'argent
public en cinq ans pour des enquêtes
d'opinion réalisées à la demande du
cabinet du président de la république et
ce sans aucun appel d'offres en 2016 le
juge d'instruction avait déjà demandé à
entendre nicolas sarkozy qui avait
refusé de se présenter cinq ans plus
tard l'ancien chef de l'état n'a plus le
choix le tribunal a ordonné que nicolas
sarkozy soit amené devant lui s'il le
faut par la force publique pour eric
ciotti cette décision relève de
l'acharnement je trouve cette rotation
une nouvelle fois un peu humiliante rien
n'aura été épargné à nicolas sarkozy on
peut même se demander s'il est un
justiciable comme les autres l'ancien
président de la république devra donc se
présenter oui mais il peut encore refusé
de prêter serment ou tout simplement ne
rien dire
la convocation de nicolas sarkozy nouvel
épisode de ce qu'on appelle la
république des juges mais évidemment un
point d'interrogation et on va en
débattre tout de suite vous présente mes
invités georges fenech monsois reçoit
ancien magistrat ancien député l air du
rhône vous publiez bataclan paris stade
de france le procès aux éditions du
rocher benjamin morel bonsoir soit
maître de conférences en droit public à
l'université paris ii panthéon assas
dominique rousseau bonsoir bienvenue à
vous aussi juriste professeur de droit
constitutionnel à l'université paris 1
panthéon sorbonne matthieu croissandeau
éditorialiste à mes côtés comme chaque
lundi chaque mercredi on va aborder en
détail la question de l'immunité
présidentielle et du bras de fer entre
nicolas sarkozy et les magistrats mais
d'abord je voudrais vous faire réagir
aux titres de notre débat quand on dit
république des juges qu'est ce que ça
vous inspire cette formule qui
sous-entend un peu une forme de
politisation de l'institution judiciaire
ou de certains juges georges fenech oui
on l'entend république des juges
gouvernement des juges la justice qui
sortirait de son lit en quelque sorte
pour s'immiscer dans un débat politique
c'est un peu un fantasme il faut bien le
reconnaître on n'est plus à l'époque de
la fronde des parlements mais pour
autant il n'y a quand même effectivement
une forme de pénétration idéologique au
sein du corps de la magistrature depuis
les années 70 disons qui s'est traduit
par le phénomène du syndicalisme avec
des prises de position politiques avec
des actes politiques aussi de la thur
politique je peux le dire et je donnerai
des exemples si vous souhaitez etc se
saouler c'est
finalement ce qui écorne quelque part
l'image d'indépendance de la justice qui
ne devrait jamais s'impliquer dans le
débat politique mais appliquer la loi
toute la loi rien que la loi dans
l'esprit du législateur
or on voit de temps en temps des mots
d'ordre de ne pas appliquer thème des
lois ou d'en faire évidemment on
l'appelle maintenant la rescousse les jo
de prudence c'est les textes européens
et autres pour écarter surtout avec la
qpc maintenant le juge a pris de plus en
plus de rôles dans effectivement dans le
débat politique mais attention il faut
pas franchir un certain seuil donc vous
dites république des jeux on exagère
mais
la peau de la politisation en tout cas
c'est à un vrai débat vos avis à la haye
le benjamin morel pour comment s'ouvrir
le gouvernement des juges c'est un vieux
sujet un expression elle date de 1911 en
réalité je crois que tu ailles voir
lambert donc c'est en réalité quelque
chose qui de tout temps a permis aux
politiques et bien de considérer qu' il
y avait une forme de pouvoir de l'ombre
qui pourrait potentiellement menacés
faut nuancer ça en réalité vous avez
deux éléments qui poussent à
généralement par les gouvernements des
juges d'un côté c'est en effet
l'intrusion du juge dans le politique
mais vous avez également besoin de
réguler les activités politiques la
question c'est dans quelle mesure eh
bien on peut réguler et surtout dans
quelle mesure on considère qu'il ne peut
y avoir faute faute parfois et d'un
autre côté dans quelle mesure il ya
parfois une décision qui relève
l'inaction gouvernementale là c'est
toute la question aujourd'hui qui est
posée par emmanuel macron notamment
envers laurent cadre de des compétences
de la cjr est ensuite maisons de justice
de la république a évoqué à l'occasion
du lancement des états généraux de la
justice avec la sphère butin est un cas
particulier mais en effet vous avez des
procédures qui sont lancés dans la cjr
qu'on peut questionner sur le fond parce
que vous avez des juges qui du coup
peuvent avoir un regard rétrospectif
donc là il faut faire attention le
deuxième élément c'est parfois des juges
qui prennent des décisions qui peuvent
apparaître comme fondamentalement
politique jurisprudence de la
conventionnelle jury cependant de la cge
est généralement ce pouvoir-là du juge
s'est jamais un pouvoir que c'est jamais
qu'un pouvoir que le politique lui a
donné quand vous constitutionnaliser des
grands principes parfois extrêmement
floue et parfois extrêmement
contradictoires et qu'ensuite vous
organisez une saisine du juge et le jury
ce que le juge doit bien tranchées et
donc à partir de là peut être que
parfois en effet il se substitue aux
politiques mais parce que le politique a
décidé de lui donner cette compétence
est donc frappé le juge pour une
compétence combien donner sa voix l'air
un peu d'une forme de schizophrénie
maire dominique rousseau république des
juges ça vous choque la forme non samsam
à chaque fois vous avez un point
d'attribuer oui j'aurais rajouté mois
des guillemets parce que si on regarde
l'histoire politique ou
constitutionnelle française j'ai eu la
république des professeurs il ya eu la
république des députés il ya eu la
république des experts et maintenant il
ya la république des juges faut être
clair il n'y a pas de république les
juges ni en réalité ni dans les mythes
dans l'une de mes ya peut-être une
politisation de certains jugent non il
n'aurait pas d'accord georges fenech non
non je pense qu'il y à une
instrumentalisation de l'expression
république des juges pour déconsidérer
l'autorité judiciaire qui est une
autorité constitutionnelle remplissant
une mission de service public et non pas
un service public c'est une autorité
constitutionnelle remplissant une
mission de service public et qui a un
rôle essentiel
dans une république qui se veut article
2 ou 3 de la constitution démocratique
quand la démocratie et repose sur deux
piliers et reposent sûr c'est pas moi
qui le dit c'est montesquieu donc je me
couvre la démocratie c'est la faculté de
statuer il faut que des décisions soient
prises mais aussi pour qui la démocratie
liberté politique disait montesquieu il
faut qu'il y ait une faculté d'empêcher
pour que celui qui statuent n'abuse pas
de sa position pour aller trop loin et
porte atteinte aux libertés
individuelles
d'où l'article de la constitution qui
dit que l'autorité judiciaire autorités
constitutionnelles et gardienne des
libertés donc quand on attaque le juge
on attaque le juge en tant qu il est
gardien des libertés individuelles et on
porte ainsi atteinte à la démocratie
donc les juges ne gouverne pas on va
entrer dans vous aurez l'occasion d'en
débattre à georges
envie de réagir vous répondrez vous
apprendrez sans aucun problème un mot
là-dessus peut-être mathieu juste pour
contrôler ans excusez georges fenech
c'est vrai qu'il peut être une irruption
de justice en matière politique mais il
ya inverse aussi aux huit rien dans une
époque de grande confusion ou un très
grand nombre de représentants politiques
commandes des décisions de justice se
mêle du déroulement de la justice et du
coup java il ya quand même
ce moment là qu'il faut décrire après
est-ce qu'on est dans une république des
juges c'est un slogan disqualifiant la
république dès juin sur et qu'est ce que
ça voudrait dire ça voudrait dire qu'en
gros l'action de l'état l'action du
politique est entravée par la justice
est ce que c'est bon
dans le cas d'espèce c'est cette affaire
qui concerne nicolas sarkozy c'est
l'action de l'état qui entravent est ce
que c'est le bon gouvernement des choses
qui est entravé le nom la question peut
être se pose effectivement pour la cjr
et sur la question de la gestion de la
crise qu vide là on va reparler mais
géré il ya le parlement qui peut exercer
ou aux mêmes parlementaires est-ce que
la justice en temps réel doit pouvoir
juger des bonnes ou des mauvaises
décisions prises par le politique là il
ya une vraie question à se poser sur un
éventuel gouvernement des jugements ou
même on n'a pas forcément well soon est
là mais la décision concernant la sphère
du siècle avec la la la la condamnation
de l'état à tenir ses promesses en
matière de changement climatique avec la
possibilité d'une astreinte à terme bref
je jouerai pas ouvrir ce débat parce
qu'on va parler là tout de suite mais
c'est comme comme ça me travaille je
voulais quand même le dire de l'immunité
présidentielle ça va être le thème
central évidemment parce que la
convocation de nicolas sarkozy par le
tribunal qui est chargé de
juger cette affaire des sondages de
l'elysée ça pose cette question avant de
vous entendre les uns et les autres
peut-être la définition quand un calme
mais je vous invite à nous rejoindre
bonsoir total à l'arrêt la règle exact
en matière d'immunité présidentielle je
vais précis parce que je parle quand
même sous le contrôle oui on
va se concentrer sur les textes nous
revenons en à la constitution l'article
67 que dit ce que dit il le prétend dans
un public n'est pas responsable des
actes accomplis en cette qualité sous
réserve des dispositions des articles 50
3-2 et 68 vous le voyez ça c'est le
début d'article 67 c'est à dire que en
fait il doit y avoir une destitution cas
de manquement grave mais dans ces cas là
c'est le parlement qui peut destituer un
président en se constituant en haute
cour ça c'est l'article 68 qui l'ont
mentionné mais la constitution elle
dispose également que le président ne
peut durant son mandat et devant aucune
juridiction ou autorité vous le voyez
être requis de témoigner non plus que
faire l'objet d'une action d'un acte
d'information d'instruction ou de
poursuite
et donc les mots sont très importants et
on voit bien durant son mandat la
décision du juge de convoquer l'ancien
président nicolas sarkozy semble donc
bien dans les clous de cet article alors
un dernier mot quand même pour évoquer
la décision de la cour de cassation dès
mi 2012 les membres du cabinet
présidentiel dispose-t-il par extension
de cette immunité présidentielle surtout
quand le décideur dans cette question
des sondages c'est bien le prénom à
public eh bien non aucune disposition
constitutionnelle est légale ou
conventionnelle ne prévoit l'immunité ou
l'irresponsabilité pénale des membres du
cabinet du prénom public c'est ce
qu'explique et bien que ce procès ait
bien lieu avec claude guéant et ses
proches de nicolas sarkozy sur le banc
des accusés thomas merci quentin quentin
calme et comme tous les jours dans son
public un zoom d'un des journalistes de
la rédaction de public sénat georges
fenech est ce que la convocation de
nicolas sarkozy est conforme ou droit
des mois j'ai une opinion sur cet
événement c'est un événement nous semble
précédent
qui n'est ni de l'andrh du registre de
la polémique encore moins la politique
je pense que cette décision de délivrer
un mandat d'amener contre l'ancien chef
de l'état n'est pas constitutionnelle
elle pattes non seulement illégal mais
elle est inconstitutionnelle le prix
dans la réplique cévennes est rappelée
bénéficie d'une immunité présidentielle
mais aussi d'une inviolabilité de sa
personne qui survit à la fin de son
mandat alors quand il s'agit de l'acte
qui relèvent de la fonction au président
pour vous ça continue à menacer chiens
et une seconde non mais attendez
imaginez une seconde qu effectivement la
force publique viennent chercher manu
militari l'ancien chef de l'état pour le
conduire sous la contrainte devant une
juridiction correctionnelle
c'en est fini de les imiter mais y
compris les imiter diplomatique demain
vous aurez un juge qui sur le tard marc
décidera de délivrer un mandat d'amener
contre poutine ou contre joe biden et le
mettre en garde à vue
c'est la fin des immunités diplomatiques
des chefs de l'état et parlementaires
également vous ne pouvez pas décorer les
ou détaché la question de
l'irresponsabilité pénale de
l'inviolabilité de la personne je
n'imagine pas une seconde que le
président macron et que gérald darmanin
laisse faire ce qui pour moi est un acte
hautement tête at war à la constitution
de là à vouloir requérir la police
nationale pour aller quérir un petit
matin un chef de l'état c'est la fin de
l'immunité présidentielle
je vous le dis mais vraiment sans esprit
polémique ni partisan c'est vraiment sur
le nez un mandat d'amener
consiste une liste alors suis pas
justement alesi dominique rousseau
le constitutionnaliste
l'article 67 a été rappelé et il y à une
immunité présidentielle durant
l'exercice du mandat et pour les actes
rattachables à l'exercice du mandat bien
et il y à un article alors vous ne
contrôlerez qui est je crois à l'article
4 139 du code de procédure pénale qui
dit que lorsque le tribunal et s'est pas
c'est par un juge c'est un tribunal et
le collégial lorsqu'un tribunal
demande un témoin de venir témoigner il
y à l'obligation c'est l'article 439 qui
le dit il a l'obligation pour le témoin
de venir témoigner et si le défi le
témoin ne veut pas venir témoigner le 4e
art et 439 prévoit la possibilité pour
le tribunal de faire de demander à la
force public d'aller chercher le tennis
n'est pas d'accord mais quand c'est
l'ancien
président a parlé
avec le constituent sont mortes et 430
salles et pas n'importe quel témoin à
new york non ce n'est pas donner moi je
ne vous cite énorme attendez vous citer
un article vous avez canal 139 je les
applique et bord de multiples fois
mandat d'amener contre un témoin
récalcitrants absolument aucun problème
sauf que là vous êtes sur un autre
registre vous êtes sûrs non pas
n'importe quel témoin vous êtes sur un
ancien chef de l'état pour lequel
l'irresponsabilité pénale survie après
la fin du mandat et l'inviolabilité sa
personne également j'entends bien qui a
pas de décisions jurisprudentielles là
dessus c'est mon interprétation et je
crois que si on met le doigt là dedans
si on peut convoquer l'ambassadeur par
exemple asador qui est en france qu'à
une unité diplomatique
non pas pour le condamner pénalement
mais pour le mettre en garde à vue pour
l'auditionner comme témoin et ses salles
est fini des minutes et des mélomanies
afin mail l'immunité elles courent très
franchement mais pas combattu normes et
brunes en plus on n'est pas comme unité
dur durant le durant le mandat de
m il redevient un citoyen et je vois pas
les actes
que je vais trancher le débat mais en
réalité l'immunité en effet cours sur le
mandat et courent ensuite sur les actes
qui ont été commis pendant le mandat 1re
manche sur l'inviolabilité je suis moins
certain je veux dire l'inviolabilité
permet de protéger la fonction des
moments où la fonction n'est plus occupé
est ce que vraiment on peut considérer
que l'inviolabilité touche au corps
l'individu si jamais on n'a vu le procès
bygmalion et qu'on avait eu un mandat
d'amener ne se poserait pas la question
alors qu'en réalité les conséquences en
termes de fonctions de la république et
des institutions soient hors est à peu
près les mêmes l'objectif encore une
fois d'immunité inviolabilité sinon pas
de couvrir une personne mais de couvrir
une fonction en l'occurrence annie
concours pas réellement et à une
deuxième question qu'on n'a pas abordé
qui je pense est comme assez importante
c'est celle en réalité du statut des
collaborateurs on a évoqué tout à
l'heure la grèce qui sont couverts par
le principe de l'immunité présidentielle
arrêtez de penser et ça a été notamment
la position de l'elysée lors de la fab
et nahla de l'elysée est un état dans
l'état en réalité non du point de vue de
la jurisprudence la cour de cassation
sur les perquisitions l'elysée n'est pas
un état dans l'état vous avez en effet
une immunité accordée à la fonction de
président de la république mais l'elysée
il ya par ailleurs et si nicolas sarkozy
n'avait pas ouvert elise est à la cour
des comptes peut être que cette affaire
n'existerait pas c'est un peu tout son
paradoxe vous avez une église et qui en
réalité est une administration peut être
importante peut-être éminente une
administration comme les autres mais
cette question elle s'est posée georges
fenech dès le début du
de cette affaire le juge d'instruction
serge tournaire qui pendant le mandat de
nicolas sarkozy ouvre ou estime qui peut
enquêter il ya eu une plainte de
l'association anticor il estime qu' peut
enquêter et il faut que la cour d'appel
s'y opposent en étant en 2011 comment
vous aviez réagi est-ce que c'était une
forme de pardon mais de provocation de
la part du journal qui savait très bien
ce qui allait se passer on d'ailleurs je
note que j'eusse tonnerre qui a pas été
très tendre avec nicolas sarkozy ne l'a
pas contraint à venir puisqu'il avait
refusé déjà pendant l'instruction
devenir comme témoin et souvenez-vous de
la jurisprudence et la position de
l'ancien procureur général de cassation
jean louis nadal qui avait dit on ne
peut même pas convoqué un chef de chefs
d'état comme témoin assisté c'est déjà
un début d' actes de poursuite attention
là vous nous dites sur une
interprétation qui vous est propre
benjamin morel l'inviolabilité ne
s'appliquent plus à la personne mais
bétonné match cela on m'aimait mais
c'est le vigor heller ses doutes
l'interprète à ces revers sont sécurisés
que dans 7 oui mais je vous fais part
affirmé je bous non plus moi je vous
donne ou non ma position à moi je
voudrais affirmer une position qui à mon
avis ne tient pas la route bien je pense
qu'elle ouvre une brèche terrible je ne
pense pas terrible sur le plan
international vous y mener les chefs de
l'état glénan passé au piquet regarde la
france entière il convoqua chef de
l'état manu militari menottes aux
poignets s'il le faut on off alors qu'il
a l'immunité présidentielle on ne
convoque pas un chef de l'état qui a
l'immunité présidentielle
on convoque un ancien chef de l'état le
parallèle que vous faites face aux
ambassadeurs et à poutine ne tient pas
apprécié routine et président de la
fédération de russie s'il vient sur le
territoire français ne sera pas
convoquée parce qu'il est président de
la fédération de russie de même pour un
ambassadeur parce qu'ils ne sont pas
protégés par leurs individualités par
leur personnalité mais par une fonction
qu'ils occupent mathieu il ya aussi la
question de la confiance des citoyens
dans les institutions le
l'impact d'une décision comme celle-là
dans l'opinion c'est quand même c'est
une dimension qui est intéressante qui
est importante mais toute la question de
savoir si les politiques sont des
justiciables les autres et le lien de
confiance entre les français et la scène
surgit siens c'est vrai qu'il est très
abîmée on en a parlé ici-même en début
de semaine et baromètres de confiance et
c'est une des institutions qu'ils plus
bas la confiance notamment pour sa
lenteur pour son opacité façon
d'illisibilité pour le pour le pour le
citoyen qui n'est pas qui n'est pas
férue de ce2 de droit et du système
judiciaire mais c'est un vrai enjeu
c'est un vrai enjeu on voit d'ailleurs
que les positions politiques changent là
dessus un emmanuel macron qui se
présentait comme un représentant du
nouveau monde qui a fait voter et
souvenez vous de sa première loi la loi
sur la transparence de la vie publique
la moralisation de la vie politique qui
devait être portée par françois bayrou
éphémère garde des sceaux il y avait un
côté on va révolutionner et puis là on
voit cinq ans après que près 5 avec
pouvoir après des démêlés
vous avez cité la sphère benalla mais on
parlait de la cjr tout à l'heure mais sa
position évoluer sa position change
c'est un élément du débat public
regardez jean luc mélenchon quand il est
convoqués et qui dit république c'est
moi ça ne me touche pas on voit bien que
la sphère politique est toujours
toujours un petit problème avec la
justice donc la justice vient se mêler
de ses affaires dominique rousseau votre
avis sur cette question particulière le
lien de confiance finalement entre les
citoyens français leur institution parce
que là sont deux institutions la
scission présidentielle l'institution
d'une sexuellement oui je crois que le
la confiance des citoyens je vais encore
cité montesquieu s'il vous permettez il
ya pire quand même comme référence mais
montesquieu disait le ressort de leur
sort de la démocratie c'est la vertu le
ressort des régimes autoritaires c'est
la crainte et le ressort des monarchies
c'est l'honneur bon nous sommes en
démocratie donc le ressort de la
démocratie c'est la vertu alors par la
vertu au sens moral chrétiens du mot
mais la vertu au civic c'est à dire la
capacité pour les hommes politiques de
penser l'intérêt général avant leurs
intérêts privés d'avoir le courage c'est
ça la vertu d'avoir le courage d'oublier
leurs intérêts privés pour ne penser que
l'intérêt général bon eh bien si les
citoyens à tort ou à raison à tort ou à
raison un
considère que aujourd'hui il va où et
quand je dis aujourd'hui depuis
plusieurs années maintenant les
les hommes politiques ils ont font
passer au moins autant leurs intérêts
privés que l'intérêt général eh bien il
ya une perte il ya une perte d'une perte
de confiance d'où le fait que les
demandes et les
citoyens
n'arrivant plus à saisir leurs hommes
politiques par le vote le service par la
justice en même temps le légalisme ils
en ont saisi quelques impôts parliez
tout à l'heure de la deûle affaire du
siècle mais l affaire du siècle c'est
simplement des juges qui demande un état
non pas de respecter les règles que le
juge a posé par les règles
donc il n'y a pas de gouvernement des
juges que dis-je les juges disent vous
avez voté l'accord de paris may l'accord
de paris bon je constate que vous le
respectez pas donc je vous condamne n'y
a pas de gouvernement des juges il ya
simplement et sa du point de vue citoyen
de la confiance est important
les juges demandent à l'état aux
politiques de respecter les lois qu'ils
ont eux-mêmes vox et où les accords
qu'ils ont eux mêmes cris et donc pour
revenir à votre question je serais
beaucoup plus inquiet d'une république
sans juge
qu'une république des juges ça
m'inquiéterait beaucoup plus un mot
là-dessus alors oui c'est un sujet mythe
multifactorielle auch est absolument
d'accord c'est à dire que le politique
encore une fois constitutionnalise ou
conventionnalisme ensuite se plaint de
ne pas avoir pouvoir alors qu'en réalité
il s'est lui même parfois lié les mains
dans des matières extrêmement importante
matière économique bah tiens
environnementale etc secteur est ce que
c'est bien est-ce que c'est pas bien en
tout cas ensuite on peut pas crier après
des juges après en revanche vous avez
une vraie question je dirais de
judiciarisation de la vie politique
cette question elle est liée à plusieurs
aspects en réalité si vous prenez par
exemple la question de la cjr vous avez
une défaillance du contrôle
parlementaire pas parce que les
parlementaires n'ont pas voulu exercer
ce contrôle parce qu'on ait des équipes
une république qui est extrêmement
déséquilibrée aujourd'hui et qu'à partir
de là et pour certains citoyens le juge
apparaît comme étant réellement à tort
ou à raison le contre-pouvoir y compris
pour certaines associations qui veulent
faire avancer des gloses en réalité si
jamais vous voulez faire avancer une
cause il est beaucoup plus facile et
beaucoup plus payant de saisir le jeu
plutôt que d'aller voir votre
parlementaire même si les sénateurs donc
là vous avez un premier élément ensuite
deuxième élément c'est le traitement
médiatique des affaires judiciaires on
n'a pas parlé de la sphère fillon et il
ya un peu un éléphant mieux de la pièce
quand on parle de la sphère filles ont
très clairement vous avez là une affaire
qui a fait bouger la compagne est ce que
cette affaire était illégitime non et
ensuite mais c'est le traitement
médiatique de la sphère en réalité qui
fait bouger à ce moment là et bien avec
une forme de huit maisons d'un magistrat
quand il lance une procédure comme celle
là il est pas responsable du traitement
médiatique mais c'est très bien alors
que la personnalité politique va être
cloué au pilori en sur la graphie lyon
quelques minutes sur la sphère figure il
ya des questions qui se posent notamment
sur le timing et là je pense que que moi
serons mieux l'expliquer il y aura il ya
également des questions qui se posent
sur les fuites qui vont paraître en
effet dans la presse mais en réalité
c'est vraiment le traitement médiatique
de la sphère qui influe ensuite sur la
carrière de françois fillon ou d'autres
politiques avec cette présomption de
culpabilité
donc beaucoup plus encore une fois que
ce contrôle par le juge qui est
nécessaire et qui est normal c'est
vraiment sud ce que l'on en fait et
comment c'est perçu par l'opinion si
vous perdez
le temps médiatique
j'écoutais les heures
le temps médiatique et le temps de la
justice n'est pas windows et n'a pas
exactement le même et si on regarde des
affaires via le temps de l'instruction
et l'instruction et est longue et quand
une instruction se termine il ya des
événements politiques qui la vendit
attise se déroule au moment où
l'instruction se termine qui n'était pas
au départ donc les échos page avec
l'événement politique encore une fois
n'est pas le fait d oui il est plutôt à
leur avantage et plutôt leur nom paris
ça on peut pas on peut pas nier même
s'ils n'en sont pas forcément oui bon ça
mais voilà alors ta georges fenech
vouliez intervenir non
je n'ai pas intervenu lors d'un débat
qui les concerne tous les deux bon ok ce
que vous ne me donnez pas la parole au
nom vous pouvez pas jouer alors je vais
vous la donner dans un court instant et
je voulais qu on se concentre sur les
relations entre nicolas sarkozy et les
magistrats et peut-être matthieu
croissandeau voir comment la droite
réagit au fur et à mesure des des
procédures visant le président où
l'ancien président la république le
sarkozy la justice ce sont ses amis qui
en parle le mieux j'ai envie de dire
dans le coma c'est assez rare en fait
dans le paysage politique il ya un
réflexe de corps autour de l'ancien chef
de l'état de par les liens qu'il a créé
avec son entourage la fidélité de pas la
façon dont ils exerçaient pouvoir de par
la peur qu'il inspire encore parfois la
moindre attaque contre lui déclenché une
levée de glaive et le bouclier le sol
autrement dit dans le paysage politique
mais les fils ça c'est jean luc
mélenchon dès qu'ils attaquaient up
toutes ses troupes qui monte au créneau
et le premier réflexe des projets
nicolas sarkozy c'est évidemment de s'en
prendre généralement à la justice et
dans un grand écart intellectuel
permanent parce qu'il faut quand même le
dire on a une droite en tout cas des
sarkozystes ne cesse de réclamer qu'on
durcisse que la justice soit plus sévère
qu'on mette fin à l'impunité judiciaire
sauf évidemment quand ça touche nicolas
sarkozy una la justice ceux qui étaient
traités de laxistes devient évidemment
beaucoup trop beaucoup trop sévère et on
assiste alors toujours aux mêmes types
d'arguments au fond qui mène
victimisation et contre attaque on a
entendu eric ciotti un shooter
acharnement judiciaire république des
juges donc démocratie malade même
parfois dérive de la justice c'était
henri guaino la dernière fois on a voulu
abattre nicolas sarkozy ça c'était le
même eric ciotti de tout à l'heure en
juin 2020 et à chaque fois enfin pas
toujours mais très souvent on ressort si
l'argument ultime qui est un peu le
point godwin en la matière qui est l'
affaire dite du mur des cons en
référence à ce plat nos d'affichage
nommé comme tel un retrait en 2013 dans
les locaux parisiens du syndicat de la
magistrature
ce syndicat est aujourd'hui ultra
minoritaire à tel point qu'ils ne
communiquent plus le nombre de ses
adhérents depuis dix ans mais crs ça
reste et sa connerie puisque c'en était
une continue d'être de polluer les
débats et de nouveau servi par les
soutiens les plus acharnés de l'ancien
président jeudi les soutiens les plus
acharnés parce qu'il ya quand même
quelque chose qui a changé il se trouve
depuis les condamnations à la prison
ferme de l'ancien chef de l'état je
précise qu'il a fait appel à chaque fois
les mots sont plus les mêmes en gros on
envoie aujourd'hui des messages d'amitié
d'affection au regard des réactions
notamment des candidats à la primaire
chez les républicains ont dit sa fierté
d'avoir travaillé avec lui mais on part
on parle de lui au passé mais on dénonce
plus de scandales on ne dénonce plus
forcément d'acharnement on dit nicolas
sarkozy était un grand président ce soit
aux cordes que les signaux faibles mais
qui en disent long à mon avis sur l'aura
déclinante l'ancien président dans son
propre camp
je reviens au début de notre débat sur
sur la politisation de certains juges
est ce que vous avez le sentiment là on
est vraiment dans cette question de bras
de fer entre nicolas sarkozy et les
magistrats qui a presque commencé au
début de son quinquennat on se souvient
de la phrase sur les petits pois qui
avait prononcé nicolas sarkozy à
l'époque qu'est ce que vous avez le
sentiment qu'il ya parfois de
l'acharnement ou des règlements de
comptes de la part de certains juges et
bien moi je j'ai mal à ma vie je ne
rentrerai pas dans ce débat qui consiste
à
sonder les reins et les coeurs du
syndicat de la magistrature en l'espèce
mais moi je regarde les actes oui mes
prises de position publiques vous disiez
ce professeur vous disiez tout à l'heure
il n'y a pas de politisation de il n'y a
pas de juge politiques d'opposition à la
justice
comment interprétez-vous qu'un syndicat
de magistrats en 2007 elle a appelé très
clairement et officiellement et
publiquement à faire battre nicolas
sarkozy est ce que vous trouvez que là
ça n'est pas un acte politique et vous
je pense que il faut faire très
attention je crois que le magistrat a
tout intérêt moi je suis tellement
attaché à l'indépendance de justice mais
l'indépendant injustice et pas
uniquement statutaire c'est aussi ne pas
sortir de son royaume moi je crois
qu'aujourd'hui il y à cette tentation
depuis quelques années depuis plusieurs
dizaines d'années mais attention ce
n'est pas uniquement sous le quinquennat
nicolas sarkozy moi je me souviens très
bien sous françois mitterrand lors de
son dernier conseil des ministres il
avait dit en 1994 un des derniers en
1994 il avait dit ne nous couvrons pas
la tête de cendres face aux défis que
les juges nous ont relancés ni la
confrontation juge politique elle est
née dans les années 80 en réalité et
elle n'a jamais cessé mais l'indépendant
injustice et est une conquête savez la
ferrure souvenez vous c'est un poncif
démocratisme georges fenech moi je pense
que la démocratie a gagné dans la
conquête de l'indépendance des juges
attention hein et tout ce qui est
instrumentalisation de la justice
évidemment il faut le condamner mais je
condamne tout autant cette forme de
politisation qui voudraient se mêler du
débat politique voyez vous c'est pour ça
je crois qu'il faut se garder
de ne pas comment vous dire il faut se
garder d'intervenir dans un débat
purement politique c'est tout l'honneur
de la magistrature mais pour cela il va
falloir accroître le statut indépendant
des mes frais notamment du parquet qui
est dans un tiroir en ce moment depuis
plusieurs années on ne veut pas faire
cette réforme du conseil national il
faut la faire la question statutaire
nomination des parquets
si vous disiez la verse et à l'heure sur
la politisation et certains actes
politiques de l'opposition
ce que j'essayais de dire c'est que les
jugements rendus par les magistrats ne
peuvent pas être accusé de politisation
d'abord passionnée collégialité d'abord
aussi un contradictoires d'abord parce
qu'il ya une motivation est d'abord et
aussi parce qu'il ya des critiques donc
les juges ne pourrait pas comme ça de
rendre une décision n'importe comment
parce que il est de droite parce qu'il
est de gauche parce qu'il est écolo
parce qu'il est macho parce qu'il est
féministe non le référent pour produire
un jugement judiciaire et pas un
jugement moral économique ou politique
c'est le coq le code pénal le code civil
le code commercial le code du travail
forcé sa le révérend pardon je retrouve
alexandre et serge tournaire quantité
d'heures ce que vous dites est vrai mais
réducteur en revanche le dominique
rousseau pas dans mes concerts je
tournais relance la procédure pendant le
mandat de nicolas sarkozy qui sait très
bien le président est couvert par son
immunité pourquoi il lance la procédure
pourquoi il accepte de prendre la
plainte est d'instruire la plainte a
bien été stoppée justement ces salles en
mettant là est ce qu'on n'est pas dans
une dérive politique d'un juge
d'instruction je pense pas vous avez des
vous avez des juges qui vous avez des
juges qui lance une procédure et c'est
ça comment dire le mérite de la justice
avec l'ailé et degrés les cours d'appel
on peut faire appel d'un juge qui a mal
interprété mal compris mal lu tel ou tel
article de la constitution ou tel
article du code et on rectifie là ou là
où je suis d'accord avec vous par
exemple c'est un peu différent comme
vous dites politisation du syndicat le
syndicat de la magistrature c'est un
syndicat donc il est jurisprudence il a
une obligation de réserve moins grande
que les magistrats les magistrats n'ont
pas à faire de politique lorsqu'il
rendait juger quand et quant à jamais
les syndicats de la magistrature peut
prendre position comme tous les autres
magistrats lors de l'élection oui non si
sauf que souvenez vous de cette fameuse
harangue oui vous la connaissez widows
val baudot paix à son âme qui disaient
ces jeunes magistrats qu'ils allaient
prendre leur fonction soyez partiaux
fait pencher la balance du côté du plus
faible soyez les défenseurs naturels du
voleur contre la police du plaideur
contre la justice de de la femme contre
le mari de l'enfant contre le père etc
etc c'est à dire que la loi vous permet
de dire ce que vous voulez avec les plus
beaux arguments du monde vous pouvez
dire le tout et son contraire et vous
savez très bien à travers photos match
c'est la faute aux législateurs non
éligible loi mais non il faut qu'il faut
que ça reste ouvert il faut que la
jurisprudence s'exprime mais il faut
dénoyautées l'institution judiciaire de
se ferment de politisation qui porte
atteinte à l'image la justice il faut
respecter des chars qui code de
déontologie
c'est un bon ici on a une approche du
rôle du juge qui est le rôle
d'interprète de la loi ce qu'il est en
réalité le juge bouche de la loi a
accepté en réalité ce n'est pas le cas
donc vous devez du coup et vous avez une
possibilité en effet de moduler la loi
et vous pouvez avoir une politisation
des juges je crois que là-dessus il faut
pas se cacher derrière son petit doigt
en considérant que le juge est par
définition est un être humain et comme
tout être humain il a des convictions
des valeurs elles peuvent être politique
et elles peuvent orienter ses jugements
la question c'est comment est ce que
l'institution même parvient à réguler et
ces individus pour justement que un juge
ayant une couleur politique
et bien ne puisse pas imposer une
décision politique et là vous avez en
effet un certain nombre de garde-fous
vous citiez la collégialité et
évidemment la procédure d'appel on
pourrait éventuellement et je vous
rejoins totalement envisager une réforme
du parquet mais au bout du compte et j'y
reviens encore le problème c'est que
avec le politique et pourquoi jean luc
mélenchon et si en colère pourquoi
nicolas sarkozy est tellement en colère
et bien cette procédure prend du temps
et le temps politique n'est pas le temps
judiciaire des moments vous êtes
convoqué comme témoin assisté des
moments où vous être mise en examen et
ses jurisprudences rocard balladur vous
démissionner quand vous êtes ministre
vous tout d'un coup votre carrière
politique apparaît système mis entre
parenthèses voire totalement terminée et
là vous avez probablement un problème
d'autant que vous avez une opinion qui
voyant de plus en plus d'affaires
judiciaires alors que la classe
politique actuelle est probablement
l'une des moins corrompus histoire pas
très populaire de le dire mais en
réalité on a tellement aujourd'hui de
transparence on a tellement justement de
capacité du juge agir sur le versement
réalité aujourd'hui par rapport à ce que
c'était dans les années 80 où là vous
aviez devrait valises de billets eh bien
vous avez aujourd'hui une classe
politique qui est extrêmement honnête
mais chaque affaire tout d'un coup fait
l'objet d'une médiatisation importante
vous avez des suites etc et vous avez
une déconsidération du politique et
l'obligation une sorte de présomption de
culpabilité à chaque fois qu'une affaire
et on s'est prononcé de logique là
judiciaire et politique aujourd'hui sont
totalement hétérogène et se met en crise
l'une l'autre je voudrais qu'on qu'on
termine par un focus sur la cour de
justice de la république vous l'avez
évoqué plusieurs fois mais je vais vous
propose de réécouter ce que le président
de la république actuel emmanuel macron
on disait lors du lancement des états
généraux
de la justice
quand des responsables ministres
fonctionnaires élus se trouve cité dans
une procédure pour une crise qui est
encore en cours nous sommes loin de
l'apaisement et de l' équilibre que
j'évoquais précédemment
et la situation que nous sommes en train
de vivre collectivement pas une question
qui peut venir mettre en tension
autorités judiciaires avec les autres
pouvoirs est-ce qu'il faut réformer ou
même supprimer la cour de justice de la
république dominique rousseau comment ça
je crois qu'il faut effectivement
réformer la cour de justice de la
république a eu des propositions qui ont
été faites dans ce sens justement pour
aller dans le sens dont parlait tout à
l'heure sur la question de l'âge de la
confiance je pense que il faut protéger
les ministres donc il ne faut pas qu'il
soit
jugé directement par une cour ordinaire
il faut qu'il ait une cour parisienne
avec une une enquête une commission
denquête qu'ils fassent le tri sur les
comment dire la qualité et le sérieux
des pleins filtre mais un filtre mais
une cour de justice de la république
comme actuellement composée de
magistrats et de
et de politiques
théorie de l'apparence a là encore une
fois à tort ou à raison n'est plus
considéré comme acceptable par pas par
la société et à mon avis à juste titre
puisque même le doyen venelles qui a été
à l'origine de cette réforme à la fin
déjà il faut supprimer cette fonderie
chez de la reconnaissance de l'histoire
d'ailleurs c'est déjà inscrit dans la
réforme à présent toujours là la
convocation du parlement en congrès mais
là où permettez moi de bien moi je suis
extrêmement choqué par le propos qui
semblent comme ça un peu anodin du
président de la république qui l'a
singer véritablement dans les procédures
en cours en parlant d' apaisement et en
donnant comme exemple des mises en
examen de madame busin etc sans les
nommer mais on l'a tous compris il ne
l'a même pas mais c'est en train
d'imaginer comment peuvent recevoir la
magistrature ce genre d'ingérence
finalement mais qu'est ce qu'il faut
faire il faut s'arrêter pendant tout le
mandat ministériel dessus recevez des
plaintes et qu'elles sont recevables
parce qu'il ya eu des fibres que le
parquet général a estimé qu'on devait
poursuivre c'est le déroulement normal
nation réussir le président la
république n'a pas alors qu'il est
lui-même garant de l'indépendance de
justice il n'a pas à dire que ces
procédures sont une en quelque sorte une
atteinte à la fonction aux politiques et
ministérielles je suis assez choqué par
ça donc j'ai la pression du politique la
wii dans la sphère
10 year we dont on disait tout à l'heure
le temps de la justice n'est pas même
que le temps la politique j'ai envie de
dire c'est valable pour tout le monde
tant d'injustices n'est pas n'est pas
coordonnée autant de la médecine quand
vous avez un médecin qui est mise en
cause dans une affaire ben toute son
activité plombé peut être arrêter le
temps de tourner ces enduits donc c'est
ça sur le médecin l'a élu pardon le
médecin n'a pas justifié de son affaire
devant ses électeurs non mais reste
devancé ses passagers à s'élancer place
à sa patientèle pardon mais je trouve en
fait la judiciarisation de la vie
politique c'est aussi un phénomène qui
touche toute la société et une
judiciarisation de tous les secteurs de
la société du salarié contre l'employeur
et développement des procédures du
consommateur devant ce qu'ils achètent
de deux des médecins enfin il ya aucune
corporation aucun secteur s'affiche à
bâle mais il donc les politiques sont
traitées d'une certaine façon et je
voulais rester une gîte une ville
d'issia risation pardon
une hypothèse c'est pas une affirmation
c'est une hypothèse explicative par
défaut oui c'est à dire c'est parce
qu'il n'ya pas parce que les conseils
d'administration des entreprises ne font
pas leur boulot que les actionnaires
minoritaires saisisse la justice c'est
parce qu'il n'y a pas de négociation
collective que les travailleurs pour se
défendre saisissent les prud'hommes
autrement dit il n'ya pas une volonté de
puissance de la justice il ya un certain
nombre d'institutions qui devrait faire
le rôle de contrôle enfin ne le font pas
et juge aujourd'hui tous les mots
exactement la sociét'halle et rien
derniers animaux il ya un problème en
effet de contre-pouvoir comme on l'avait
déjà évoqué c'est à dire que très
clairement quand vous n'êtes pas
d'autres contre-pouvoir les citoyens se
tournent vers les jugez vous avez une
question également en terme de moralité
c'est à dire qu'aujourd'hui pour
beaucoup citoyens grosso modo les
idéologies non plus réellement sens pour
une grande partie de nos concitoyens
l'efficacité du politique est également
remis en doute si vous avez un politique
qui n'est pas vraiment perçu comme
efficace et qui n'est pas vraiment perçu
comme cohérent idéologiquement et bien
voulu demander au moins d'être moral et
ça c'est un mouvement qui aujourd'hui
touchent les politiques et qui explique
aujourd'hui aussi un peu le rôle du juge
époque on se tourne vers lui merci
beaucoup merci à tous les trois d'avoir
participé à ce débat enfin il rappelle
le titre de votre livre bataclan paris
stade de france le procès publié aux
éditions
du rocher on passe